you're talking about like testing things
last night with the podcast we were
doing man and you know what's funny
people you overthink it's not even
testing it's like put [__] out it's like
being a comedian like comedians like go
and try [__] out they're testing it by
[__] doing it yeah yeah by the way
you're testing it one Tick Tock that's
gonna get more listens than a whole
[__] badass song on [__]
SoundCloud or Spotify There's real
[__] eyes and ears out there there's
two words self-awareness and self-esteem
if you're self-aware you don't try to do
things you can't do you focus on things
you do like you don't try to be
something you're not if you have
self-esteem you're not scared to put it
out the content the video the picture
the audio because you're not worried if
Sally pants 49 thinks you're ugly